ni rimbaud dont on pourrait imaginer à
travers l'acteur la dégaine ni portraits
d'auteurs prodige dont il réfléchit la
création denis lavant et ce pur produit
d'un siècle dont l'art en mouvement
autorise toutes les urgences y compris
d'avoir du talent et notamment une
question qu'on me pose un as dans le
film d'un mauvais sens 10 mais est ce
que comme att est ce que tu avais
toujours cette tête pas comment tu étais
quand tu étais petit et moi je réponds
j'ai été un très beau bébé voilà et
c'est vrai au théâtre de la bastille où
il joue avec ce lyrisme qui fait partie
du personnage denis lavant est aussi
constantin gavrilovic les routes
tourmentées de la mouette de tchekhov
deux identités pas toujours parallèle
[Musique]
au théâtre impression qu'on est plus
porteur d'une pensée ou d'un d'un jeu
qui plus est plus physique comme ça que
plus une silhouette mais qu au cinéma
une une présence aesthetic plastic qui
est très importante
et quant à mon physique vous dites je
sais pas je pense pas que je la vision
que j'ai de moi voyons un film sur les
visages
il ya à la fois je ne me reconnais que
je reconnais denis lavant mais je vois
particulièrement dans ce film pour
mauvais sens je vois je vois un autre
personnage vivre sous mes yeux
vous prenez autre chose vous avez des
tartes maison qu'est ce que vous appelez
mais aussi quelques drapeaux les maisons
les choses que je fais sur son parti de
ma vie donc me plaisent ponctuellement
donc dans ce sens là oui je suis je me
sens bien ensuite je sais pas si on peut
dire
je passe il ya des comédiens qui peuvent
dire qu'ils se sentent bien dans leur
peau dorée qui essayent il s'efforce de
changer à chaque fois c'est qu'ils ont
besoin d'un relais d'autres personnages
pour exister
[Musique]